bonjour je suis Gwenola bigouin la
directrice de l'espace Alphonse d'udé à
coanière aujourd'hui je vous conseille
un spectacle La Nuit des rois d'après
[Musique]
Shakespeare alors la première euh bonne
raison de voir ce spectacle c'est un
classique mais accessible à tous la mise
en scène est contemporaine par exemple
les décors en fait sont minimalistes ce
qui laisse place à l'imagination et
cetera les costumes sont entre hier et
aujourd'hui et surtout le langage est
actuel la deuxième bonne raison c'est un
spectacle dynamique avec six comédiens
pour 15 personnages c'est un spectacle
où on danse ù on chante ou on
s'interpelle comme au 17e siècle mais au
son des guitares la troisème bonne
raison c'est une joyeuse farandole une
fresque musicale et clownesque qui
célèbre la fête le travestissement et
l'amour surtout et en cet en rose ça ne
peut faire que du bien bon parle
sérieusement fait de l'effet comme de
l'utre vie sur une s pas pas pe
[Musique]
rule c'était donc les trois bonnes
raisons pour voir la Nuit des
rois